اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات في
العناوين
قررنا ياهو تاجيل التعديلات القضائيه يثير
الجدل المعارضه تعتبره مناوره والمحتجون
يتمسكون بالشارع
القوات الروسيه تسيطر على المنطقه
الصناعيه بالكامل في بخموت وتفتح جبهه
عنيفه في ابديفكا في دنيا
مع وصول حامله طائره امريكيه الى سول رئيس
كوريا الشماليه يدعو لتعزيز صناعه الاسلحه
النوويه
مجلس النواب الامريكي يصدر اول مذكره
استدعاء
لكشف وثائق تتعلق بالانسحاب من افغانستان
اهلا بكم اكبر ازمه في تاريخ اسرائيل
مشاهدينا هكذا وصفها زعيم المعارضه
الاسرائيليه يئير اللذيذ الازمه لم تنتهي
بقرار رئيس الوزراء بنيامين نتنياهو والذي
اعلن في نهايه يوم المحتدم امنيا وسياسيا
فقد اعلن قاده الاحتجاجات في اسرائيل
استمرارهم في التظاهر رغم خطاب نتنياهو
الذي اعلن فيه تاجيل التعديلات القضائيه
وقال قاده لاحتجاجات ان نتنياهو يناور
بتاجيل التعديلات من اجل تمريرها لاحقا
بعد اضعاف الضغط الشعبي طبعا مشددين على
انهم لن يبتلعوا هذا الطعم واخطر ما وقع
حتى الان في موجه التظاهرات هذه هو انضمام
عدد متنامي من قوات الاحتياط العمود
الفقري للجيش الاسرائيلي الى المتظاهرين
الذين رفضوا الحضور للخدمه مطلقين بذلك
صافرات انذار بان الازمه باتت تهدد امن
اسرائيل حكومه نتنياهو تقول انها تسعى
لجعل النظام القضائي اكثر الليبراليه والى
ان يكون تعيين القضاه الجدد بعيدا عن
التسيس وهو ماء ترفضه المعارضه وتطالب
بوقف كامل لكل تلك التعديلات المقترحه
[موسيقى]
وفي ردود الفعل على قراري نتنياهو رحب
البيت الابيض بتاجيل خطته للاصلاح القضائي
وقالت المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض كارين
جون بير في لقاء صحفي قالت ان اداره بايدن
تواصل حث القاده الاسرائيليين على ايجاد
حل وسط في اقرب وقت ممكن
نرحب بهذا الاعلان كفرصه لايجاد المزيد من
الوقت للتسويه التسويه هي بالضبط ما كنا
نطالب به نواصل حتى القاده الاسرائيليين
على ايجاد حل وسط في اقرب وقت ممكن نعتقد
انه افضل طريق للمضي قدما لاسرائيل
للتواصل الى هذه التسويه يتم تقويه
المجتمعات الديمقراطيه من خلال الضوابط
والتوازنات ويجب متابعه التغيرات الاساسيه
للنظام الديمقراطي باوسع قاعده ممكنه من
الدعم الشعبي
من القدس ينضم الينا المحلل السياسي
لنيسان اهلا بك معنا سيد ايلي اذن
احتجاجات مستمره رغم تصريحات نتنياهو
بتاجيل هذه القرارات ماذا يطلبون المحتجون
يريدون الغاء هذه القرارات تماما وهل يمكن
ان يلتزم بالفعل نتنياهو بالغائها
والان اريد ان اقول هذه الديمقراطيه التي
نشهدها في البلاد شاهدنا في الاسابيع
الاثنى عشره الاخيره مظاهرات
ومواجهات واضرابات ولكن الكل كان واعي
بانه يترتب ان يحافظ على البيت البيت
المقدس هنا في اسرائيل
الان
ولكن لمس خلال كل هذه المظاهرات لم نرى
سفدنا لم نرى قتل في الشوارع كما كان في
في ايران وهذا هو الفرق الكبير بين
الديمقراطيه وبين الديكتاتوريه على سبيل
المثال في ايران في المحادثات التي ستبدا
خلال الايام القليله القادمه بطبع سنرى
عدم ثقه بين الجهات بين الحكومه
وبين المعارضه ولكن عندما تسلم رئيس
الدوله هرتوك زمام الامور
والتحدث مع رئيس الوزراء ومع اركان
المعارضه
وتم تشكيل لجان من قبل كل الاطراف
لبدء المحادثات في هذا الموضوع وهذه هي
هذه هي بدايه جيده وحسنه
في المحادثات سنرى مدا وجدرا في هذه
المحادثات ايضا راينا نتنياه يطرح خطه
حوار سيد ايلي برايك ماذا يمكن ان تتضمن
هذه الخطه
الخطه التي يطرحها
رئيس الوزراء طبعا هي الخطه التي طرحها
قبل عشره ايام
وعندما
قبلها
اركان المعارضه ولكن نتنياهو رفض هذه
الاقتراح وكان من
اقتراح سيد ايلي ثم رفض الاقتراح الذي هو
اقترحه
ورفض اقتراح رئيس الدوله
واعتقد ان نتنياهو
استيقظ من ثباته بعد الشيء متاخرا لانه
اذا كان ياخذ بجديه اقتراح رئيس الدوله
بهذا الموضوع لما كان نرى المظاهرات
وصدمات في الشوارع ولذلك اعتقد ان كل
الاطراف من الطرفين الحكومه والمعارضه
وصلوا الى الصواب الصحيفه هذا الموضوع
واقول شيء مهم حتى الحكومه والى لها
اغلبيه 64 عضو كنيست
لها اغلبيه عليها ان تاخذ
بالحسبان
المعارضه
وحتى هي قويه عليها ان تاخذ بالاعتبار
الضعيف وهنا اعتقد ان الكل توصلوا الى
تفاهماته سنرى مظاهرات بعض الشيء من قبل
النواه القوي الذي لا يريد الذي لا يثق
بنتنياهو ويقول اننا نتحدث عن هذه
المعارضات والمظاهرات سيد ايلي ولكن دعنا
نستعرض استطلاع رايي صدر بالامس ثم اعود
اليك
مشاهدينا لخصت استطلاع استطلاعات راي
نشرتها القناه اثني عشر عن اي انتخابات
مقبله لخصت المشهد في اسرائيل حيث اظهرت
الاستطلاعات انهيار الليكود الى 25 مقعدا
وخساره
الكتله اليمينيه عشره مقاعد على الاقل
فيما يصبح بني جانس اقوى بشكل ملحوظ وفق
الاستطلاعات فان حزب الليكود بزعامه بن
يمينه نتنياهو سيتراجع من 32 الى 25 مقعدا
في الكنيست ولفت الاستطلاع ايضا مشاهدينا
الى ان حزب المعسكر الوطني بزعامه جانس
سيعزز فرصه لتجاوز حزب يعيش عتيد وبناء
عليه تحصل اعزاب الائتلاف الحكومي السابق
على 61 عضو كنيس من اصل 120 فيما يحصل
تحالف الجبهه العربيه للتغيير على 5 مقاعد
ويحصل التجمع الوطني الديمقراطي على
2.1% من اصوات الناخبين اعود اليك السيد
ايلي يعني كل هذه الارقام وتراجع لك ود
وعلى ما يبدو يعني تقدم المعارضه الى ماذا
تشير
اولا هذه تشير الى الصفحه التي تتبدها
رئيس الوزراء واللكوت خلال هذه الاسابيع
من المظاهرات ثانيا في الكود كانت هناك
تعالجت الاصوات ان نتنياهو
وزير العدل
سيؤديان الى تحطم الكود
ويعيده الى مكان في الماضي الى 12 مقعدا
ولذلك اعتقد ان نتنياهو راى ولربما كان
واعي بكل ما يحدث بان هناك انخفاض في
شعبيه الليكود الشعبيه رئيس الوزراء
وارتفاع
حزب
الا ان جانس
تصرف بشكل رسمي وبشكل يعني يخدم الامور
الامور السياسيه والقوميه باسرائيل
من ان تدني في عدد الاصوات في الكنيست من
32 عضو كنيسه اليوم الى 25
هذا يدل ان الشخص اسرائيل لم يكن راضي من
تعامل رئيس الوزراء مع امكانيه تطبيق
الاصلاحات
وشعبيه نتنياهو تتراجع وتواجد الكود
يتراجع في الكنيس كذلك هل تسمعني سيد
ايلين
هل تسمعني
طيب كنت اسالك عن هذا التراجع وتراجع
لشعبيه نتنياهو كما ذكرت كيف يؤثر على
مستقبل نتنياهو السياسي في ظل هذه
الاحتجاجات والمعارضات والتراجع الذي
نشهدوا في كل من الكنيسه شعبيتو
نعم طبعا الاستطلاعات تشير فقط للوقت التي
من يجري هذه الاستطلاعات ولكن اذا نتنياهو
يعرف كيف يتعامل مع الامور
ويتصرف بشكل رسمي وياخذ بالحسبان ايضا
مطالب المعارضه اعتقد ان في نهايه الامر
لان
الامور تعود الى مجراها لان الشارع في
اسرائيل هو شارع يمني وكل ما رايناه في
الاستطلاعات التي رايناها يوم امس في كافه
القنوات تدني في شعبيه رئيس الوزراء بمعنى
ان الشعب لم يكن راضي مما قام به رئيس
الوزراء خلال الاسابيع الاخيره واعتقد ان
بعد بدء المفاوضات واذا المفاوضات
تشهد تقدما طبعا برعايه رئيس الدوله اعتقد
ان الامور ستعود الى مجراه لان تعلمين
تماما يوم امس عندما اجري هذا الاستطلاع
كانت هناك اضرابات في كفه المرافق
الاقتصاديه في الموانئ وفي
تراجع هذه الاحتجاجات بعد كلمه نتنياهو
للاسف انتهى وقتي معك سيد ايلي نيسان شكرا
جزيلا لك المحلل السياسي من القدس
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
نشرتنا مستمره وفيها بعد الفاصل
بتكلفه باهظه وخسائر فادحه روسيا تتقدم في
ابديه
اهلا بكم من جديد في اخر التطورات
الميدانيه في معركه باخموت اعلنت السلطات
دونيس المواليه لروسيا ان القوات الروسيه
سيطرت بالفعل على المنطقه الصناعيه في
بخموت بالكامل وقامت بتطهيرها من القوات
الاوكرانيه وفي موازاه ذلك اشار القائد
السابق لكتيبه ايدار الاوكرانيه وهي منظمه
محظوره في روسيا اشار الى ان الوحدات
الروسيه تطوق بخموت بشكل شبه كامل بحسب ما
نقلت عنه وكاله الروسيه ووفقا لقائد
الكتيبه فقد حقق الجيش الروسي تقدما كبيرا
في محيط افديركا في دونيتك واكدت متحدثه
باسم وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه ان بلادها
تسلم الدبابات تشالنجر البريطانيه من دون
ان تحدد عددها كما ان وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني اوليكسي ريزنكوف قال ان او قال
ان الوحدات الاوكرانيه حصلت على دبابات
تشالنجر البريطانيه ومدرعات سترايكر
وكوغار الامريكيه وماردر الالمانيه ومن
المتوقع مشاركتها في اي هجوم اوكرانيا في
الربيع حول ذلك ينضم الينا منك
البابا بدايه لنتحدث عن المعارك على الارض
كيف تجري وما الجديد هناك
نعم بالفعل يعني صباح الخير ولكن بالبدايه
الحدث الابرز هو استهداف العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كييف بالامس بمسيارات يعني
اطلقت على على العاصمه الاوكرانيه اكثر من
ثمانيه عشر مسيره اطلقت باتجاه الاراضي
الاوكرانيه الدفاعات الجويه في محيط
العاصمه الاوكرانيه داخل عاصمه
13 مسيره ووقعت انفجارات في عده احياء في
العاصمه الاوكرانيه عند الساعه العاشره
حتى الساعه الواحده مساء سفارات الانذار
دوت بعد سواق انفجارات عن نيفا هزت
العاصمه الاوكرانيه كيف بفعل هذا
الاستهداف ليله امس الذي جاء رد على
استهداف اوكرانيا او كما اتهمت روسيا
واوكرانيا باستهداف محيط يعني العاصمه
الروسيه موسكو بين مسيره تم اسقاطها ومما
ادى الى اصابات ليله امس بحسب معلوماته من
الاداره العسكريه لمدينه كييف هناك اكثر
من خمس اصابات بسبب
المسيرات التي سقطت واحنا المسيرات سقطت
على احدى المحال التجاريه سوبر ماركت مما
ادى الى احتراقها بالكامل في منطقه صالون
خسرت اوكرانيا بخمود كما تتحدث الانباء
ماذا يعني ذلك للجانب الاوكراني
من الناحيه الاخرى يعني المعلومات التي
ذكرت في النشره هي مغايره للمعلومات التي
تصل للاعلام الاوكراني عبر وزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه عفوا
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه تقول ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تسيطر والان هي تقوم بالمبادره
بالهجوم على بالهجوم المدفعي على منطقه
يعني تدمير الخطوط الدفاعيه للجيش الروسي
خاصه ان رئيس الاوكراني قبل يومين اعلن او
وجه يعني امر للقوات العسكريه القوات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه بمهاجمه منطقه
السوليدار ايضا يعني في منطقه بخبط وبحسب
ما يتداول من وكالات الانباء ومن يعني
وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه والجيش الاوكراني
والحرس القومي الاوكراني انه وتيره الهجوم
الروسي في تلك المنطقه خفت بشكل كبير جدا
يعني 80% تراجع قدره القوات الروسيه لم
تسيطر بالكامل على المنطقه الصناعيه في
باخموت ولم تطهرها من القوات الاوكرانيه
المنطقه الصناعيه هي منطقه المنطقه
المنطقه الصناعيه هي منطقه تقع في الجهه
الشرقيه التي دخلتها القوات الروسيه قبل
ثلاثه اسابيع وكان هناك اشتباكات مستمره
حتى هذه اللحظه يعني ليله امس خرج احد
الشخصيات المعروفه في اوكرانيا وهو سيد
ابراهيم واحد المشايخ الذي يعني ترك الدين
وترك يعني رسالته الدينيه وانضم الى
القوات الاوكرانيه كمصعب خرج من داخل
مدينه وتحدث على عبر وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي وقال ان القوات الاوكرانيه الان
لديها او تمتلك زمام المبادره في الدفاع
وابعاد القوات الروسيه وان الوضع في اليوم
افضل من ثلاثه اسابيع من الفتره وايضا
لديها الدبابات من تشالنجر وغيره من
الدبابات الامريكيه والبريطانيه
والالمانيه كذلك وصلت الى هناك شكرا لك من
كييف الصحفي محمد البابا اوكرانيا ولم تصل
الى الجبهات حتى هذه اللحظه شكرا اوكرانيا
لم يتم نشرها على الجبهات حتى واضح شكرا
لك
وصف الرئيس الاوكراني فولدمير وضع محطه
زابوريجيا بان روسيا تحتجزها كراهين
لمدير عام الوكاله الدوليه لطاقه دارية
جروسي انه لا يمكن ضمان الامان في المحطه
النوويه الا عند خروج القوات الروسيه منها
جاء ذلك بعدما التقى
لتوليد الكهرباء بالطاقه المائيه والواقعه
شمال شرقي محطه زابوريا اعلنت وزاره
الخارجيه اليابانيه انها تراقب عن كتب
الانشطه العسكريه الروسيه قرباء مياهها
الاقليميه مشيره الى ان النشاطات العسكريه
الروسيه اصبحت اكثر نشاطا في بحر الشرق
ياتي هذا ردا مشاهدينا على اطلاق البحريه
الروسيه صاروخا اسرع من الصوت ضمن مناورات
في مياه البحر اليابان وذكرت الدفاع
الروسيه في بيان لها ان الزوارق الصاروخيه
لاصطول المحيط الهادئ اطلقت صواريخ كروز
موسكيت على هدف بحري وهمي لعدو في بحر
اليابان واشارت الى ان الصواريخ اصابه
اهدافها بنجاح
ما بين روسيا وايران علاقه تتوضا تتوضد
حتى في مجال الحروب الالكترونيه حيث قالت
مصادر مطلعه لصحيفه
موسكو تعمق تحالفها العسكري مع طهران
لمساعدتها في اكتساب قدرات مراقبه رقميه
متقدمه اتسعى طهران للحصول على المساعده
السبرانيه من موسكو وقال المحللون انها
تركز في الغالب على شبكات الدفاع
الالكتروني وياتي هذا التعاون بعد ان باعت
ايران طائرات مسيره لروسيا لاستخدامها في
اوكرانيا كما زودت روسيا ايران بقدرات
مراقبه الاتصالات بالاضافه الى اجهزه تصنت
واجهزه تصوير متطوره واجهزه كشف الكذب
بحسب اشخاص مطلعين على الامر طبعا واكدت
المصادر المشاهدين ان موسكو شاركت بالفعل
مع ايران في برمجيات اكثر تقدما من شانها
ان تسمح لها باختراق هواتف وانظمه
المعارضين موضحين ان السلطات الروسيه قررت
ان فوائد تعزيز العلاقات العسكريه مع
ايران تفوق اي سلبيات
افادت وكاله الانباء السعوديه
والنوايا العهد السعودي ورئيس الوزراء
الامير محمد بن سلمان اجره اتصالا هاتفيا
مع الرئيس الصيني وجرى خلال الاتصال
التاكيد على اهميه العلاقات الاستراتيجيه
التي تجمع البلدين واعرب ولي العهد
السعودي عن تقدير المملكه للمبادره
الصينيه لدعم جهود تطوير علاقات حسن
الجوار بينها وبين ايران
نشرتنا تستمر مشاهدينا وفيها
قيود طالبان مستمرا الحركه تعتقل مؤسس
شبكه مدارس لتعليم الفتيات
قرارنا التنياهو تاجيل التعديلات القضائيه
يثير الجدل المعارضه تعتبره مناوره
والمحتجون يتمسكون بالشارع
القوات الروسيه تسيطر على المنطقه
الصناعيه بالكامل في بخموت وتفتح جبهه
عنيفه في افديفكا في دنيتك
مع وصول حامله طائرات امريكيه الى سول
رئيس كوريا الشماليه يدعو لتعزيز صناعه
الاسلحه النوويه
ومجلس النواب الامريكي يصدر يصدر اول
مذكره استدعاء لبلانكن وذلك لكشف وثائق
تتعلق بالانسحاب من افغانستان
حياكم الله من جديد وصلت حامله الطائرات
الامريكيه يو اس اس
والتي تعمل بالطاقه النوويه الى قاعده
بوسان البحريه في كوريا الجنوبيه ووصلت
الحامله لتشارك في تدريبات عسكريه ولتعزز
التعاون الدفاعي بين كوريا الجنوبيه
والولايات المتحده الرئيس الكوري الشمالي
كيم جونغ اون مشاهدينا دعا الى انتاج
المزيد من المواد النوويه والتي يمكن
استخدامها في صنع الاسلحه بهدف تعزيز
ترسانه بلاده وفق ما نقلته وكاله الانباء
الكوريه وتفقد كيم برامج الاسلحه النوويه
لبلاده كما اختبر خطط عمليات شن هجوم نووي
مضاد واشار ايضا الى انه يمكن لان تكون
مستعده لاستخدام هذه الاسلحه في اي وقت
وعلى خلفيه الانسحاب الامريكي من
افغانستان والذي وصف بالفوضوي كما شاهدنا
مشاهدينا وقع رئيس لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه
في مجلس النواب الامريكي مايكل مكول وقع
مذكره استدعاء لوزير الخارجيه انكن لكشف
وثائق تتعلق بالانسحاب الامريكي من
افغانستان وقال ماكول في بيانكن رفض الرد
على الاتهامات التي تطاله بهذا الشان ما
دفعه الى اصدار اول مذكره استدعاء بصفته
رئيس للجنه واعلنت بعثه الامم المتحده في
افغانستان انا سلطات طالبان اعتقلت مطيعا
الله وويسا وهو مؤسس شبكه مدارس لتعليم
الفتيات وطالبت البعثه في بيان لها
بالافراج عنه والكشف عن اسباب اعتقاله
ومكان وجوده
ينحدر من ولايه قندهار ان عمله خالي من
السياسه وان تركيزه على المساعده في تعليم
الفتيات الاف اللاجئين الافغان قد يصبحون
بلا ماوى في بريطانيا حيث كشفت صحيفه دي
البريطانيه ان حكومه البلاد ستجبر ما يقرب
من 9000 افغاني على مغادره فنادق المملكه
المتحده كما اعلن وزير المحاربين القدامى
جوني ميرسير انه سيتم اخطار اللاجئين قبل
النقل ببضعه اشهر على ان تتم عمليه نقلهم
في غضون اسابيع واشارت الصحيفه الى ان
الاطار الزمني سيختلف اعتمادا على الفندق
لكن الحد الادنى للاشعار سيكون ثلاثه اشهر
وذلك نظرا لوجود هدف لدى الحكومه لاخلاء
جميع الفنادق بحلول نهايه العام الجاري
اصيبت الحياه في المانيا بشلل شبه تام في
جميع انحاء البلاد خلال احد اكبر
الاضرابات منذ عقود الاضطرابات التي جاءت
في وقت تعاني فيها المانيا من التضخم
اربكت ملايين الاشخاص في بدايه الاسبوع
الحالي خصوصا مع تعطل السكك الحديديه بعد
مشاركه اكثر من 30 الف من العاملين فيها
في الاضرابات ما جعل ملايين من الركاب
مشاهدين الذين يعتمدون على الحافلات
والقطارات يعانون من هذا الاضراب بطبيعه
الحال بالاضافه الى الغاء العديد من
الرحلات الجويه في معظم مطارات المانيا
منها مطار ميونخ وفانكفورت تنظم النقابات
العماليه في فرنسا مشاهدينا يوما عاشرا من
الاحتجاجات على مستوى البلاد فيما تستمر
الاضرابات بعد ان خيمت على مسيرات او
مسيرات الاسبوع الماضي اعمال عنف في
الشوارع تعد الاسوا منذ اعوام كما يرى
البعض وسيشمل هذا التحرك الشعبي والنقابي
عده قطاعات من بينها التعليم والصحه نقل
والطاقه وكان اخر تحرك ضد رفع سن التقاعد
الخميس الماضي قد شهد نزول ثلاثه ملايين
ونصف المليون متظاهر الى الشوارع في فرنسا
وفقا للنقابات فيما تحدثت وزاره الداخليه
حينها عن حوالي مليون وتسعين الف متظاهر
للمزيد حول ذلك ينضم الينا من باريس مراسل
العربيه حسين جنيبر اهلا بك حسين اذا
انباء تتحدث عن تجدد المظاهرات اليوم حول
سن حول رفع سن التقاعد انقل لدينا اخر
المعلومات لديك
اهلا بك فاطمه بالفعل تظاهر مركزيه ستنطلق
من ساحه الجمهوريه عند الساعه الثانيه من
بعد الظهر ساحه الجمهوريه هنا في باريس
هذه التظاهره المركزيه تتعلق بالعاصمه
وحدها ولكن التحركات الشعبيه والنقابيه
ستشمل اليوم عده مدن كبرى اذكر من بينها
بالاضافه الى باريس اليوم ومارسيليا
وتولوز ونيس وكان بالاضافه الى بوردو
سبور وعددا كبيرا من المدن الاخرى الكبرى
والمتوسطه
والصغرى هذا التحرك ستواكبه القوى الامنيه
من خلال انتشار 13 الف شرطي ودركي عبر
فرنسا من بينهم 5500 سينتشرون في العاصمه
وحدها وزير الداخليه
دغمنانا حذر من وج مخاطره كبيره
الاحتمالات اندلاعي اعمال عنف واخلال
بالنظام العام متحدثا عن وجود حواله الف
عنصر متطرف قال انهم ينتمون الى اليسار
المتطرف بعضهم ينتمي الى اليسار المتطرف
وبعضهم قادم من خارج فرنسا سيلتحقون بموكب
التظاهرات في باريس وهؤلاء بعضهم سيقوم
ايضا باعمال العنف في مدن بوردو
واليون وديجو تحدث وزير الداخليه عن وجود
عناصر من اقصى اليسار ومن اليسار المتطرف
يهدفون الى الحاق الاذى بعناصر الامن وقال
ان
891 شرطيا ودركيا جرحوا في فرنسا منذ
السادس عشر من هذا الشهر في اعمال عنف
توزعت عبر انحاء البلاد واضيف اليهم سبعه
واربعون عنصرا امنيا جرحوا يوم السبت
الماضي في مواجهات اخرى منفصله تتعلق
بالاحتجاج على اقامه مخازن للغايه الزراعي
ابار عفوا وسدود للراي الزراعي طيب هل من
بوادر عن اي تراجع ربما للرئيس عن هذه
القرارات ام هناك اصرار على هذه القرارات
برغم الاحتجاجات
الرئيس حتى الان يبدو مصرا على تنفيذ
قانون سن التقاعد بدءا من شهر ايلول
سبتمبر المقبل لانه يعتبر كما الحكومه ان
نظام التقاعد يعاني من عجز سيبلغ عام 2030
عشرين مليار يورو بفعل ارتفاع معدل اعمار
الفرنسيين المعدل الوسطي للاعمار الذي
ارتفع خلال عقود الاخيره يفرض تمديد العمل
عامين اضافيين من الثانيه والستين الى
الرابعه والستين براي الحكومه المخرج
الوحيد قد يكون من خلال وساطه دعت اليها
النقابات نقابه رئيسيتان دعت الى وساطه
بين هذه النقابات والسلطه التنفيذيه والا
فان الكلمه الاخيره ستكون للمجلس الدستوري
الذي سيبط بالامر بعد ثلاثه اسابيع فاذا
ايد الحكومه ستكون هناك احتمالات باندلاع
مواجهات عنيفه جديده فاطمه شكرا
حكومه بولنديه مشاهدينا اوسط او هيئه
حكومه بولنديه اوسط بحظر تطبيق تيك توك
على هواتف موظفي الاداره العامه التوصيات
ليست ملزمه للحكومه لكنها اشارت الى
ايجابيه ازاله التطبيق الصيني من هواتف
العمل
وفي جلسه الكونجرس التي ادى فيها الرئيس
التنفيذي للتيك توك بشهادته حول المخاوف
من التطبيق اثرت موجه سخريه من قبل
مستخدمي تيك توك والامريكيين بشكل عام
بعد الجلسه الشهيره في الكونجرس للرئيس
التنفيذي لتيك توك امام لجنه مجلس النواب
للطاقه والتجاره اعتبر العديد من مستخدمي
تيك توك ان اعضاء الكونغرس لا يعرفون كيف
تعمل التكنولوجيا ومنفصلون عن العصر
الحديث
الاسئله التي وجهت الى تيوب كانت عنيفه
وجعلت الرئيس الشاب عاجزا عن الاجابه في
كثير من الاحيان لا لعدم امتلاكه الاجوبه
الشافيه ولكن للصعوبه فهم الكثير من
النقاط التي طرحت كما حصل هنا لنسمع سؤال
ان
هل باستطاع التيك توك الدخول على شبكه
الواي فاي الخاصه بمنزلي
عذرا لم افهم السؤال
التيك توك الدخول على شبكه الواي فاي
الخاصه بمنزلي
اما اجابه احد المستخدمين فكانت هذا سخيف
اسئله ممثل الامه الامريكيه اثارت موجه
كبيره من السخريه لدى الشباب على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي وخاصه مستخدمي تيك توك
الذين اعتبروا انها دليل على استهداف
التطبيق الشهري بعينه تيك توك لا يختلف
ابدا عن منصات وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
الاخرى مثل فيسبوك وتويتر وانستجرام وفي
الحقيقه فان مشروع تكساس الذي يطرح الان
من قبل تيك توك مهم للغايه ولكن المخاوف
من امكانيه اختراق الحكومه الصينيه
للحسابات الامريكيه قائمه دائما جمع
الحزبين الرئيسيين في جبهه واحده تماما
كما فعل
ولكن في المقابل نظم بعض النواب من مناهضي
حظر التطبيق وقفه احتجاجيه مخالفه تماما
لما رايناه داخل الجلسه وهذان ابله امريكي
شمال بومن يقول
التعديل الاول يقفل لنا حريه التعبير
وبحضر تيك توك نحن نخالف هذا الحق ونحن
نمنع منصه جمعتنا وساعدتنا على النمو
باعمالنا الى مستوى اخر ان حظر تيك توك
سخيف
وامام هذا الكم الهائل من التعليقات على
الجلسه الشهيره اعتبرت صحيفه نيويورك
تايمز
نقلت الى واشنطن اكثر من 30 مؤثرا على
المنصه للدفاع عن التطبيق بعد جلسه
الاستماع
ريتا سليمان العربيه واشنطن
في رمضان مشاهدينا لا يختلف ليل عدن عن
نهارها فرغم تبعات الحرب وتاثيراتها
الاقتصاديه الا ان اليمنيين يصرون على
احياء طقوس الشهر الفضيل الروحيه
والاجتماعيه كجزء من عادات وتقاليد
متوارثه رغم ارتفاع الاسعار وتدني قيمه
العمله الوطنيه وضعف القدره الشرائيه
للمواطنين التقرير من ردفاند بيس
[موسيقى]
على الرغم من الظروف الاقتصاديه الصعبه
هكذا تبدو اسواق مدينه عدن في بدايه الشهر
الفضيل الازدحام سيد الموقف والحركه
التجاريه والاقتصاديه على اشدها والمحلات
ممتلئه بالمتسوقين والباعه ينتشرون في كل
مكان ابناء عدن عندنا باقواء خاصه مميزه
لاستقبال رمضان وعشر رمضان من اقوى نفحات
ايمانيه رائعه وعدت تقاليد بالماكولات
والمشروبات وتلاقي حتى نفسيات الناس بشكل
دائم نفسيها سمحه ومتقبله للاوضاع حتى
الوضع شويه متدهوره لكن الحمد لله ربك يسر
الامور
ولرمضان هنا اطعمه وسلع تجعل للشهر الكريم
طابعا خاصا
كجزء من عادات وتقاليد متوارثه من القدم
ورغم الحرب المشتعله في البلاد منذ انقلاب
الحوت عام 2014
وما خلفته من ازمات انسانيه ومعيشيه الا
ان اليمانيين يسرون على احياء طقوس وشعائر
شهر رمضان
كمناسبه دينيه واجتماعيه لها نكهتها الخاص
هنا في مدينه عدن العاصمه المؤقته العادات
والتقاليد في عدن الحمد لله الاسواق يعني
الانوار بكل مكان والاضاءات وعدم جميله
جدا بشعبها والناس طيبين والزيارات
الحمد لله رغمة لكن نحن عايشين
لا يختلفوا ليل عدم في رمضان عنا نهارها
حيث تتزين المدينه في كل احيائها خصوصا
العتيقه منها وتفتح الاسواق ابوابها حتى
ساعات الفجر
اذن هذه المره استقبلت هذا الشهر الكريم
استقبال حافل ومبهر الزينات في الشوارع
كانت ملفته للنظر
الى خلاف كل عام لا تنام غدا في شهر رمضان
حيث يوحي كلما في هذه المدينه بطابع خاص
للشهر الكريم الذي يصر الناس هنا لاحياء
شعائره والمحافظه على طابعه الروحي
والاجتماعي ردفان دبيس العربيه عدل
الى موسم رمضان ومشاركه الفنانين العرب في
الدراما المصريه حيث تتنوع هذه المشاركه
لتشمل الدراما بكل انواعها الضوء على بعض
هذه الاعمال والمشاركات وراي النقاد فيها
في فقرات كواليس مع الزميله سهى الوعل
واعداد ايهم القاسم
[موسيقى]
احنا اواني اللقاء
مرحبا تستقبل الدراما المصريه هذا العام
العديد من النجوم العرب حيث يمثل في معظم
الاعمال النجم او اثنين واحيانا اكثر في
المسلسل لتكون قصته مصريه وانتاج مصري
وربما تم تصويره بالكامل في مصر فكيف
ينعكس هذا الامر على العمل وعلى الفنان
وما مدى اهميته لكليهما كل امر الفنانين
السوريين ولا لبنانيين ولا بشتغلوا بمصر
ولا التوانسه يعني ما في هذا الموضوع صار
اخر كم سنه بينحكى فيه بالاول ما يعني
صباح ما كانوا لبنانيه ولا مصريه ولا فريد
الاطرش يعني
ما بنخلص يعني في عدد كبير من النجوم
العرب اللي اشتغلوا بمصر ونجحوا وحقوا
ذاتهم حتى المصريين ما بيعرفوا شو جنسيته
الحقيقي نجوم العرب المتواجدين في الدراما
المصريه هذا العام الفنان السعودي محمد
القز اللي يشارك غاده عبد الرازق بطوله
مسلسل تلتي ثلاثه فرح بسيس هو خالد القيش
من سوريا امام خالد النبوي في رساله
الامام في ريال يوسف من تونس امام سهير
رمزي في ليله ام البنات جهاد سعد من سوريا
امام روجينا في ستهم وشمس الكويتيه امام
كوكبه من النجوم في سر بالنسبه لي حلمي
يعني اي فنان في الوطن العربي بيحب يشتغل
في مصر ده تحدي وده نعمه وده حاجه جميله
جدا انك تقدم نفسك للجمهور المصري اللي هو
انا اعتبره من اصعب الجماهير الفنيه
الموجوده في الوطن العربي لانه جمهور ناقد
اللهجه اصلا في حياتي العاديه بتشكل مشكله
فانا بتكلم ثلاث لهجات في جمله واحده يعني
احيانا نتكلم سعودي بعد ثواني اقلب مصري
بعدين سوري بعدين بس اللهجه المصريه
انا عندي تحدي هنا اني الجمهور لو تقبل
الشخصيه مش هيضايق كتير
نجوم العرب باهتمام فمن كانوا هؤلاء
النجوم
[موسيقى]
الورقه فيها شويه الغاز حاولت حلها عن
طريق بحث وتدقيق
لسلطان امل
[موسيقى]
الى العناوين
قرارنا ياهو تاجيل التعديلات القضائيه
يثير الجدل المعارضه تعتبره مناوره
والمحتجون يتمسكون بالشارع
القوات الروسيه تسيطر على المنطقه
الصناعيه بالكامل في بخموت وتفتح جبهه
عنيفه في ابديفكا في دنيتك
مع وصول حامله الطائرات الامريكيه الى سول
رئيس كوريا الشماليه يدعو لتعزيز صناعه
الاسلحه النوويه
مجلس النواب الامريكي يصدر اول مذكره
استدعاء
لكشف وثائق تتعلق بالانسحاب من افغانستان
دمتم في امان الله